- yeah
sometimes
what what up can't see what what y'all
see
we do a documentary a documentary I'm
Clarissa little sister the boxer
no I'm our little sister fool yeah yeah
yeah thank you
good-looking fella
tonight I am the best in the box on the
work grew up in Flint Michigan I have
this in the world a little bit of
pressure for Clarissa to be the first
Olympic gold medal
I love Clarissa Loretta Shields heels
will arrest you
so truly in inspiration
a lot of people don't even know me a lot
of people just delight that's Claressa
sister
I have no problem with that but don't be
like oh that's Claressa sister she need
to go do with our sister doing no I
don't everybody always trying to compare
me to Clarissa
but this is my life
at the same time a lot of stuff that I
think it's okay it's really not okay
a lot of us have Flint are stuck inside
of our own world because we saw used to
struggling
I got used to my mom adore me out at
three o'clock in the morning
I'm used to dealing and buying food
stamps just to make ends meet I'm used
to not having to listen to nobody
because I was always kind of doing not
write by myself
when Clarissa last me I really took that
she hard but I had a body Butler had to
lead to really succeed her life
I feel like Loretta meant to be on TV
and I meant to be in the streets
what if Clarissa were to stay with me
what if Clarissa ran the streets with me
we were both too [ __ ] up out here with
nothing
I never wanted my son names to be
Bradford he been fed that he since the
womb before reason found out if he was a
boy or not he was sad daddy even if he
was a came out a girl he was do come you
fat daddy full time Fred daddy mama
that's what I am that's my life now Fred
had it up with the bread at a couple
dusters on come on fat daddy I was
thinking to you
it is so easy huh it's hair grow back we
saw on your back a week
baby out soon come here look at me Oh
handsome
you better sale I wanted to get pregnant
I want to have a baby because I felt
abandoned by everybody everybody chose
when they want to care love me or
whatever so see if I have my own baby
he already gone want is me are you gonna
need is me and all you're gonna love
this me are you gonna keep all love them
till they die you never never stop I
wanted my own baby
whatever yeah yeah we going to the zoo
the rest is really living her life sorry
see our [ __ ] together now I gotta get my
[ __ ] together
he tries to do something in my life I'm
capable of doing that I can't let my
situation define who I am I can't let
that make me
I'm a statistic but that's not all I am
I'm worried